[Music]
Wolfgang I just saw Avengers infinity
war and it was amazing like seriously it
was everything I hoped it would be it
was perfect it was just it was
ridiculous I mean from seeing all of the
characters interact with each other
seeing them on screen at the same time
seeing star-lord and Thor who are my two
favorites talked to each other and see
him interact it was funny and it was
serious and it was epic it was
everything that I truly wanted to movie
to be I mean it wasn't it's almost like
it wasn't even real I remember sitting
in the theater and it was starting and
it just it just didn't seem real still
doesn't seem real it's like I'm dreaming
this right now because it really was
just that good I wasn't disappointed in
the slightest there's nothing that I
would have really changed about it I
mean it sir I'm I'm on a high right now
right an Avengers high from just seeing
the movie came straight from the theater
here record a video for you guys but I
mean seriously I'm just I'm on cloud
nine it was amazing I'm shaking I've
been shaking since the start of the
movie really I was on I was literally on
the edge of my seat the entire time I I
was always on the edge of my seat there
was never a time where it wasn't
entertaining or I just didn't know what
was gonna happen or there was a fight
scene or or something but I'm literally
I'm literally shaking right now I
haven't stopped since after the movie
and if you've seen it already you you
know why right you know why you've seen
it you've seen what happens during it
you've seen the ending I it ended how I
wanted it to end like pretty dang exact
to how I wanted it to end and I'm not
giving away any spoilers in this video
I'm gonna do another video tomorrow and
it's gonna have my a real reaction with
spoilers but I didn't want to do that
today I just wanted to say that the
movie was amazing like truly it was
everything that I wanted I hope
everybody loves it because I think it's
the best Marvel movie there is so far it
was just it was done perfectly if you
followed me from the beginning really
and you've seen my videos on the
theories that I've had
and the theories that have been out
there in the ones that I thought would
come true I was pretty I was pretty
right for the most part there was some
that I was wrong on something that
happened but if you watch some of my
videos there's a lot that actually does
happen and that I just maybe like just
like conceded I guess but I was really
really excited that they happened and oh
my gosh get the Russo brothers trolled
us hard like hard there were some there
were a lot of scenes that were in the
trailers that were not in the movie
really like when they said that they
shot fake scenes they definitely shot
some fake scenes and you'll understand
what I mean when you see the movie and
like I don't I don't want to say anymore
because I don't want to give anything
away in this video and a part of me
needs to just sit here and like reflect
on what happened and I pardon me to just
I just need to go back to the theater
right now because I mean there were
times in the movie where I was just like
I need a time out like there's so much
like awesomeness happening that I just I
just need a quick timeout like if they
would've given me a five-minute break in
the middle of the movie I could have
just like okay this is really happening
like this this just happened and I mean
that's really what I needed I need that
time right now and I don't want to give
any spoilers away but a lot of you asked
me to give my thoughts on it once I saw
it and it's just like even if you didn't
ask me honestly I'd do it because it was
amazing so if you haven't seen it go see
it do not wait go the second that you
can go trust me one of you left a
comment saying that you were gonna
either see it tomorrow or next week
tomorrow like go see it tomorrow I'm
sorry I I don't remember exactly who it
was but go see it tomorrow anyone if
you're debating when to see it if you're
waiting for a group of friends go see it
alone who cares just go see it what okay
my editor just told me that it was
awesome TJ Greene awesome TJ green go
see it tomorrow
don't wait a week I could I could keep
talking I really could guess I could
just talk about it all night and I will
tomorrow tomorrow we'll talk about
actually what happened in the movie and
it will have spoilers just a heads up if
you're gonna
that tomorrow you haven't seen it don't
don't watch it really I don't want to
ruin it for you guys but I just wanted
to say that it was just it was amazing
it was perfect I was on the edge of my
seat the whole entire time it wasn't
real it really really wasn't real it was
crazy
so go see it I hope you all love it as
much as I did really go see it as soon
as you can and again if you go see the
movie and you dress up or if you go with
friends you go by yourself and you can
take some pictures send them to my
Twitter you can tweet at me or you can
send me a DM and don't forget about the
speaker system giveaway that we're doing
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave like and comment what
your favorite superhero is that could be
Marvel DC any superhero but in this
video leave a comment below what you
thought of the movie if you've seen it
already I want to know exactly what you
guys think I will try to reply to
everybody I I love it I want to talk
about it so please please let me know in
the comments below I try not to do any
spoilers for those who haven't seen it
so that'll be tomorrow's video we can
put as many spoilers as we want in
tomorrow's video because those who
haven't seen it have been warned so
again guys it was awesome perfect I
loved it I've seen it again like a
million more times go see it thank you
so much for watching
woof woof build a statue for me with my
helmet on with the Big Ben the oils I
would say father
enjoy babe I didn't do it for him
[Music]